hello everyone and welcome to one of the
greatest chess puzzles i've uh
i've probably seen in a very very long
time it's i'm amazed that i have not
seen this one uh as of yet uh i mean
i've been in into chess for quite some
time now and this one has eluded me up
until a few days ago when i uh saw it on
twitter it's a really an amazing chess
problem you guys will enjoy solving it
it's a forced checkmate in nine moves
and it's uh i don't want to spoil
anything because this is the this is
something that you want to you want to
print out and you know have it on you or
wherever you go so you can you know show
it to everyone to your friends at the
bar in the library and
it's just uh it's just incredible you
know if if the aliens ever visit us this
is the thing that we should show them
like this is what we were doing all all
this time
and they will be very impressed you know
that we weren't just uh
wasting our time but because it's so so
incredible so now feel free to pause the
video and try to solve it it's a forced
mate in nine but uh if you can't solve
it don't watch the video i will show the
solution in the video
but this is i believe a problem you can
enjoy for for a very very long time uh
so you know uh maybe maybe just stop and
return to the video maybe tomorrow maybe
in a week maybe in a month maybe uh who
knows maybe you can just use this
problem to have a good time with your
with your friends whenever you're out
it's uh and i mean anything is possible
uh so yeah there you have it try and try
and solve it uh it's um uh yeah it's a
problem from i believe 1850 i mean it
was a very a long long time ago so when
something is like 150 or 200 years old
that there's always some uh historical
inaccuracy but for those of you who are
interested in learning more about this
um and about conrad the bear also
he worked
under the pseudonym of draconrabe
sometimes i will put a link in the
description below the first thing you
will see an article by edward winter
where there is quite a lot of
information but getting back to the
problem
i hope you are ready for it because uh
here it comes so one thing that you
probably uh thought about when uh when
going about this problem was bishop
captures on g6 and while this is a a key
move
to solve this problem it's not the one
that we're starting with because after
bishop captures king captures a 97 check
uh of course you are winning but you
don't have a forced checkmate in nine
for from the starting position here
black can just capture the queen as uh
you are also in check and when the white
queen captures you're going to play
bishop captures an a4 and now okay white
will still win but it's nothing that we
would be making a video about so the
real uh
beauty behind the position is uh rook to
b7 this is the move you had to find and
it comes with the very
uh very uh distinct threat of bringing
the queen to g8 so you want to sacrifice
the bishop here put the king on g6 and
move the black queen away from the
control over of the g8 square so here
queen captures on b7 if you don't
capture the rook just wrote captures on
f7 is checkmate so the rook has to be
captured uh queen captures on b7 and now
only now bishop captures on g6 king
captures this is the only move now comes
queen to g8 with check and now you have
to capture the knight as well if you
just move the king then queen to g4 is
checkmate the knight covers the h6
square
so after queen to g8 check and of course
this is impossible we just capture the
queen so nothing uh nothing good is
happening here uh king captures on f5
and now comes queen the g4 with check we
have king to e5 and now you think all
right we finally solved it the d4 ends
the game and while that is true it ends
the game in 10 moves from the starting
position so that's not a checkmate in
nine but it's also a nice one so we will
show it knight captures on d4 queen
captures with czech king f5 will repeat
queen g for checking the e5 now queen to
h5 with check f5 and now finally we open
up this diagonal queen to h8 chuck queen
to g7 only move and queen captures will
be checkmate the king covers the d6
square the rook covers all of these
squares and that's uh that's it
uh but we have to do it in the quickest
way possible so there is an even nicer
uh checkmate here queen to h5 with check
now if you play f5 then we repeat this
queen to h8 idea and after queen to g7
is checkmate so we can't do that uh so
instead of uh uh uh moving the pawn to
f5 we're gonna play rook to f5 and this
seems like a good idea because now we've
activated our pieces that will help out
with the defense of the black king
but now not queen captures an h do we
check because that would only prolong
the mating sequence but rather f4 with
check uh here what do you play if knight
captures on f4 then rook to e4 check and
it's game over d captures on e4 and the
d4
check will now be checkmate so of course
we don't want to capture with the knight
we're going to capture with the bishop
as this is the best way to defend but
now comes the move you have to see all
the way back when you played rook to b7
and that is queen captures on e2 we're
even gonna show this one in slow motion
queen captures on e2
with check so there's absolutely nothing
you can do here if bishop p3 we just
capture this with checkmate and if of
course the queen is captured then we
sacrifice the rook as well and we have
sacrificed everything that we could have
uh
accept that one pawn that we will
deliver checkmate so the captures on e4
and now d for checkmate and we have
successfully sacrificed everything the
pawn delivers checkmate and have you
ever seen anything quite like this
now of course we've shown a lot of
sidelines so just uh for those of you
who want to uh memorize it or you wanna
print screen it or even print it to have
it on you at all times uh so rook b7
taking control over the g8 square queen
captures now we give up the bishop king
captures queen the g8 check we give up
the knight uh now comes queen to g for
check king the e5 now queen h5 check a
critical continuation here
rook to f5 and now of course f4 with
check we give up the pawn bishop
captures next we give up the queen queen
captures on e2 bishop captures and
finally we give up the rook so we give
up everything to deliver this
spectacular checkmate uh i mean
i am i'm at a loss for words so i'm just
gonna end the video here and you know uh
let you guys soak it up because this is
this is uh i mean wow
uh so yeah that's the that's the problem
i really hope you guys enjoyed it i i
was so amazed when i saw it because okay
of course i did not see all the chess
problems
that exist but i i'm pretty sure i saw
all the all the
crazy ones and all the super interesting
ones but this one eluded me for so long
so i'm incredibly happy that i was able
to share this one with you uh yeah once
again and that's the problem hope you
guys enjoyed it if you want to learn
more about conrad bear and about the the
problem itself first link in the
description below takes you to the
edward winter uh article about it
i would like to thank claudio bravely
and alessandro bossi yoga spatchi
donating because it is the strongest
move uh persolba kentare kaldalal and
rip market for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and truly
congratulations who to everyone who
solved this over over the course of the
video
see you soon